はい 今日は私の性格と同じく悪い天気で
大変皆様たくさん集まれていただきましてありがとうございます
で いろいろ 多田千晶さんとかね
協会の方々 一生懸命苦労して
いろんな講演会できる場所を探したりして
今日も初めてこの講演会場でね
講演できるようにと一生懸命頑張っていただきまして
協会の関係の方々にも深く感謝いたします
今日はちょっと時間的にはきついということになっていて
私のようなこのダラダラダラダラダラダラね
時間気にしないで喋るということは今日はちょっとできなくなります
はい では話に入ります
仏教は共存学ということで
友杭の連鎖を乗り越えるということになります
で あの この間ね まあ一昨日かな
和製カルチャーの講演でね
このテーマを知らなかったんですけど
そのその前の日しか調べないんですね
それでまあ そのテーマに必要なことを全部スイスイ喋ってしまったんです
だから あの だいたい私の性格っていうのは
あまりリピートはしたくないんですね
で まあそういうことだから
ちょっと損したような皆様方はね
気がしますけど まあ私は損していないんだからね
大丈夫でしょうね で あの
人間っていうのは不思議な存在でね
あの 同じ同士で殺し合いやってるんですね
で 同じ仲間を殺すっていうことは
他の動物の中でないんですよ
魚は結構魚食べてますけど
同じものは食べないんですね
仲間は食べないんですね
人間はあまり別にキャニバリズムというわけじゃないんだけど
そこもなかったわけじゃないんですよ
人間殺して食べたこともないということはないんだけどね
しかし 食べるために殺すならばそれでもいいんですけど
ただ殺すんですよ 人間が人間を
で かなりおかしいんですね
それから人間同士でむちゃくちゃ競争する
戦う 足を引っ張る で 憎しも恨も
それから誰も信頼しない
で 決して生活してはいけない社会環境といえば人間の社会なんですね
ものすごく危ないんですよ
だからまあ 3 3つぐらい鍵をかけたりして
セコム会社にも金払って生活しなくちゃいけないんですね
で 建物に入るとね ちゃんとあちらこちらあちらこちらクローズドサーキットが終わったりしてね
まあ顔を全部記録しておくんですね
誰が入ったかとかね これ
誰が怖がってますかね？誰が誰を怖がっていますか？人間のことでしょう
だから そんなおかしにへっちゃらな気分でね
気楽に生きていられるわけじゃないんですよ
人間が怖いんですよ じゃあクマに殺された世界の人間のカースト
あるいは他の動物でもいいんですよ
ゾウとかね サメとかね
1年 そういう動物に殺された人間のカースト
人間に殺された数をね
比較しましょうか 私は今日データを持っていないんですけどね
で 亡くなったのはわかるでしょう
この日本でも毎日のようなニュースでね
誰が殺されたっていうことは出てくるでしょう
でもクマに殺されたっていうことはなかなかないでしょう
なのにクマは信頼しないんだけど
人間は信頼するというね
とんでもない生命ですね
親に殺される場合もあるし
旦那に殺される場合もあるし
奥さんに殺される場合もあるし
恋人に殺される場合もあるし
友達に殺される場合もあるし
それであのっ 生活するために収入が必要でしょ
儲からなくちゃ金儲からなくちゃいけないんですね
金儲かる時でも 誰かに損を与えて儲かってますね
誰かにダメージを与えて
ひどい目に遭わせて儲かってますね
では 被害者は誰ですか？といえば
これまた人間なんですね
まあへっちゃらでライバル会社はもう潰しちゃいますよ
で あの この証券の世界
株 株の世界っていうのはね
あれはもう地球上であってはならないほど恐ろしいシステムでしょうに
どれほど人間 一文のない人間に陥れるのかと
何のこともなく このサブプライム問題とかなんとかってね
リーマンショックやらいろんなことでね
何人かが ただ何人かが
世界の財産全部パーにダメにするんですね
だけど 面白いことは そういう人々には裁判もなく
罰もなく 他の人々はその苦しみを受けなくちゃいけないんです
というわけで 人間というのはとても尊い
ありがたい存在です それで一番汚いのは
人類こそ唯一の優れている存在であるとまた言うこと
どれほど汚いかというと
これはヒットラーが私ほどユダヤ人を心配する人間はいませんよというような話でしょう
だから神が地球上で生命を作って
その種を通して王を通して人間も作りましたと
偉いんだと 人間は それでわかるでしょ
人間っていうのは他の動物と違って
なんかえらく頭が悪いんですね
そういうところを今日説明していきたいと思いますが
仏教の話ですから そんな人を馬鹿にすることをね
まあ世の中ではね 人間ほど素晴らしい
尊い 立派で もう何でもできる存在がないというとてつもない錯覚に
幻覚に 妄想 概念に洗脳に陥っていますから
それはそのまま放っておいて
私に関係ないんだからね
一応 お釈迦様のお話に戻りたいと思います
で 人間のこの争いっていうのは
この醜い争いっていうのは
ただ私の言葉で言えば
単純に餌探しが拡大しただけなんです
これ 餌探しと言わなくちゃいけないんですよ
皆様 自分食べることに餌っていう言葉さえ使わないでしょう
これは動物食べるもので
とんでもない失礼でしょ
なんで動物は餌食べて
我々はご飯を食べているんですかね
なんで同じ言葉を使わないんですかね
なんだこの差別 誰でも食べ物を食べて生きてるでしょうに
で 自分の国の言葉ではね
差別しませんよ 決して犬に餌が餌あげたかと言わないんです
同じ言葉を使うんです
あの子供に食べ物をあげてくださいと
ご飯をあげてくださいと
同時に それ終わったら犬にもご飯をあげて
それから牛がいるんだからね
牛もちゃんとご飯食べるためにちょっと外に出してくださいとかね
みんなご飯なんです だからこの言葉
これは仏教経なんですけどね
そこで我々は 人間はご飯で
動物は餌でという差別
他を馬鹿にするってことになっているんですね
で 私がだからあえて餌という言葉を人間にも使っているんですね
だから皆様はこの外人だから日本語知らないだろうと思って許してくれますから
どうぞ許してください
日本語知らないんだから使ってます
で これは人間のこの醜い恐ろしい存在になったのは
単純に餌を探すことがあまりにも拡大しただけなんです
ハゲタカっていうんですか
この動物死んじゃったら
それ食べる アフリカにいるんですね
でっかい鳥がね 頭が禿げてますね
で ワシでしたっけね ハゲワシというね
ハゲタカ 何でしたっけ？えっ？ハゲタカ
私はテレビで見たらね
自分が餌取っていると
他のワシが手変わってくると追い出したりはします
時々くちばしから自分取ったりもします
これも同じ種類で争いですけど
その程度で終わっちゃうんです
殺したりはしないんです
怪我させたりはしないんです
他のハゲタカたちに 餌を取れないように特権は取りません
特許は取りません で カラスの場合は餌を見つけたら仲間を呼ぶんです
一人で食べない で しかし
皆様から見れば カラスというのは一番悪い鳥でしょ
みんな大嫌いでしょ それはその通りで
ものすごくいい鳥なんです
頭が良くて で 人のこともよく理解して
自分に親切だなと思ったら
その人間には全く迷惑をかけないで
カラスを飼ってみたってもね
はちゃめちゃ面白いんですよ
歌うは 喋るは 遊ぶはよく喋りますよ
わかってるかどうかはわかりませんだけど
飼ってる人と一緒に犬みたいに後ろから行くわ
それから困ったことは
自分気に入ったものをどこかで見つけたらプレゼントで持ってくるんですね
飼い主に で そこまでカラス性格いいんですよ
でもカラスは好きなのは光るものだからね
光るものを見つけたら持ってくるんですね
これが大事な他人のものだったら結構困りますけどね
で だから人間に嫌われてるんですよ
特に日本では嫌われてる鳥なんですね
人間というのはなんかこの餌探すこと
とてつもなく拡大して
もう自然まで破壊して
動植物を破壊して 地球を破壊して
我々も死に落とし入れて
結局は毒を食べさせているところまで
で拡大するんですね はい
これまとめて言えば簡単に相当頭が悪いということになるんです
だからもうちょっと最低動物程度でもね
頭が良くなった方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますけど
仏教はそんなものではなくて
人間は人間の次元を超えてしっかりした智慧が開発しない限りは
周りにいる人々はみんな怖いという
この誰に殺されるかわからないということをね
この危険な状態はなくならないんですね
ですから お釈迦様は我々のは超人法というものを教えているんですね
別にあんた 私が悪口言ったんだからってで
動物の程度でも知識あった方がいいんじゃないかということではなくて
やっぱり人間の次元を超えてくださいという話なんですね
これでこの問題はどこから始まるかというと
このすべての生命に生きていきたいという希望があるんですね
で すべての生命はなんで生きていきたいと思っているのかというと
知らないんですね すごいシンプルな答えなんですね
もしかすると生きていられないんじゃないんですかね
これ 無視するだけで 動物も無視しているかどうか話聞いたことはないんですけど
我々人間がそれを無視しているだけで生きていきたいと思っているんですね
生きていられるならば
わざわざ思う必要ないでしょう
誰も呼吸したい 呼吸と思っていないでしょう
だって簡単にできるんだから
当たり前にできることだから
それは全く希望する必要はないでしょう
で 生きていきたいことだけはものすごく必死で希望して頑張っているんですね
ということは生きていられないんですよ
で 生きていられないんだから
我々はこの存在 生存の競争というものが始まるんです
そこはポイントです 生きている
生き 生きるために 生存するために競争するんです
戦うんです 競争しなかったら生きていられないんです
死んじゃうんです これはあまりにも醜い戦いになっていますね
強者が生き残り 強者が生き残り
弱者は消えます これが現実です
次 強者が弱者になります
なって消えます ずっと強者でいられるわけじゃないんです
弱者になります なって死にます
海にいるクジラも強者ですけどね
誰もクジラを食ってやるぞとは思わないんです
人間以外は一部の で しかし
クジラさんも年取りますね
体が弱くなりますね それで他の魚たちはそれを食べるんです
で 体が小さくたってもしょうがない
その時は体小さい元気な魚が強者なんです
ということで 生きるということは
こういう何かとんでもない循環になっているんですね
競争する 生存の競争 これが醜くなる
残酷に弱者を殺す それで強者である自分もすぐ弱者になって殺されるということが生きることなんです
誰もこの競争には勝てま
勝ちません そういうわけで
誰も勝てません 勝ちませんよ
勝った人もいません これで私たちは勝つ方法がないのかと求めるんです
いわゆる自分が強者になって
もうとことん弱者を殺せる
殺せる方法はないのかと
生き残る方法 永遠になる方法
敵を破壊する方法ばかり考えているんです
人間の知識も科学もそんなもんなんですよ
学問も 宗教 政治 経済 文化などもなど
何でも勝つ方法 生き残る方法のみを求めるんです
なんで学校に行って学ぶんですかね
勝つためですよ 強者になるためですよ
生き残るためなんです
別に学問が素晴らしいんだからじゃないんです
これによって私は良い立派な人間になりますでは全くないでしょう
科学研究は何のためやら
では 宗教の話聞いてみてください
汝らは神の子だからね
ということを言うでしょ
だから強者であると嘘を言うんです
で 宗教っていうのは決まって嘘を言うんです
真理は言わない 事実は言わないんですね
だからそこはよく覚えてください
では 文化についてどうですかね
文化って別に美しいものでしょ
そうじゃないんです 文化で我々は仲間を作って固まって強者になるんです
お祭りやったりとか これで仲間意識を作って強者になるんです
それからしきたり習慣があるでしょ
それでかなり厳しいんですよ
それは で それで強者たちが生き残るんですね
イスラム文化っていうのは
あまり教えが大したくだらないものですけど
パクった教えですからね
その代わりにあらゆるしきたり
女は顔を人に顔を出て髪の毛見せてはいけない
運転してはいけないとかね
男が運転した車に女が乗ったら
まあもう 40回鞭打って刑務所に入れなくちゃいけないんだとかね
で 偉大なるサウジアラビアの法律ですね
女は仕事をしてはいけないとかね
で そういう風に まあ厳しいことを作って
男たちは強者になって
女たちを踏みつけて生活する
ただ争いが醜くなっていくだけで
そういうことだから 我々の争いが醜くなるんですよ
科学は発展したことで
原子爆弾やら大量破壊兵器やらステルスという飛行機やら
そんなものができただけでしょ
恐ろしい船なんて 公募とかね
飛行機に乗って着陸できる空母
もう大量にあるんで だから中国も作ってますよ
ものすごいたくさん どこからでも攻撃してやるぞってことでしょ
で 文化をもって人を殺すわ
もう何でもこういうこと
宗教で人を殺すわ 政治理念で人を殺すわ
短い人生はさらに苦難に陥りますね
これで 我々には暇がないんで
人を殺すことで忙しいんです
間接的でももう参加しているんでしょ
人類を破滅に陥り 陥れることに
命の本当の姿って何なのかと
有機物を取り入れないと体は存続しないんです
これが他の生命を奪うことになります
有機物を取り入れると
皆さん何か分からないと思うでしょう
私はこの生命はすべて同じという立場でこういう言葉を選ぶんですよ
たとえミミズであろうとも
有機物を食べないと生きていられません
我々も有機物を食べているんです
有機物っていうのは結局は生命なんです
しかし 食料になる目的で生まれる生命はいません
ここでややこしいところは
私は生き物を食べなきゃ生きていられないんだけど
だったら私に食べられるためにどこかで生命が現れてあった方がいいでしょうに
いないんです 誰も誰かに食われるために生まれるわけじゃないんです
イワシの群れとかね サケに攻撃されると必死ですよ
命を守るために でも全部食べられますけど
これよく考えてください
この地球上でどんな生命も誰かに食べられる目的で生まれてないんです
必死で生きたがる 死を避けたがる
他の生命を残酷に奪って生きているんです
だから我々は食べるということ自体が残酷な行為ですよ
殺さないでくれと 必死で怯えて逃げ回った生命を
強者だから 取って殺してやったんです
だから相手がかわいそうやと思っちゃうと
これできないことなんです
生存欲と残酷な競争はセットです
これ離れません で 残念ですよ
状況は誰でも生きていきたいんですよ
なんでこの生存欲あるのかというと
ちょっとしたことで死ぬんですよ
ちょっとしたことで死ぬ
だから怯えているんですね
これで死にたくないということも生存欲なんですね
生きていきたいという気持ちはすべての生命にあるんですね
それと同時に残酷ということが一緒になっちゃうんです
生きていきたいならば
その道を歩まなくちゃいけない
その道が残酷です それで我々は次のテーマ
戦いの構えというものをね
戦いに戦おう 残酷に戦おう
でも構えなきゃダメですからね
だから戦うためには弱みがあったら困ります
だから我々はいろんな方法で強者になろうとするんです
一つは 他の生命を心配すると
他の生命にも生きる権利があると認めるならば
自分に競争することができなくなります
だから我々は自分の人権についてはすごいうるさいんだけど
他の生命の人権については
生きる権利についてはまるっきり無関心です
動物を殺しても死刑にはなりません
はい そういうことで 我々はこの心を残酷にするんですよ
人間は殺すのはまずいんだけど
怖いんだから まあ動物は殺すのは構わない
ある日本人に聞いたんですけど
魚を釣るのは一向に構わないんだ
何ですかと聞いたら 魚には痛みは
魚は痛みは感じませんと
あれは嘘ですけどね 痛みは感じなかったら殺してもいいっていうことでしょう
だったら人間に麻酔かけて殺せばいいでしょ
だって痛み感じませんから
だからこの なんですごい胸を張ってそういう屁理屈を言うのは黙っていたんだけどね
で 言うんでしょうかというと
やっぱりこれ こういう法則なんですよ
だから自分が残酷な生命になって
それで強者だと それから食べるために創造された
命を守る目的なら 殺すのは正しいという立場まで作るんですね
聖書ではもうコーランでもね
動物は食べるために神が作ったんだと言ってるんです
言いながら なんじらは豚食うなよと
旧約聖書でも豚食うなよとあります
なんだこりゃと 食べてはあかんだったら作らなくていいでしょうに
バカじゃないんですかね
またあれ食べてはあかん
カレー食べてはあかんとか
食べてはいけないもの
また次から次へと出てくる
食べるために作ったならば
何でも食っちゃえばいいでしょうに
ウシも食うために作ったんだから
じゃあゆかりでもゆかりの葉でも食べてくださいよ
トリカブトとかね こんな明確な嘘をみんな信じてるでしょ
だから残酷ですよ 我々は
強者になりたくて頭がおかしくなっているんです
理性がなくなっているんです
理性って初めからもない
理性あったら困るんですよ
この残酷な醜い戦いできなくなるんです
軍人になったらね アメリカではとっくにマインドコントロールするでしょ
いろんなことで で 麻薬も何でも OK にするんですよ
戦争終わったらみんな廃人になっちゃって
アメリカ政府は何も面倒を見てあげないんです
イラク戦争でね むちゃくちゃ劣化ウラン作って
みんな被爆しちゃって
認めませんと 科学的な根拠はありませんと
みんな却下 勝手に死になさいと
それで宗教に関係なくても
人間がやっぱり食べるためには
やっぱり魚を殺さなくちゃ
ニワトリ殺さなくちゃ
豚を殺さなくちゃということになっている
ウシを殺さなくちゃとかね
それから正当防衛という人殺しも OK にするんですね
はい なんでそういう考えがあるのかというと
やっぱり強者になるための構えですね
これが それから相手が悪い
皆に迷惑 価値のある存在ではないなどの差別的な立場
人間というのは本当にものすごい差別的なんですね
で アメリカはね 黒人差別で奴隷までシステムを作ってね
いまだに差別は消えてない
これで南アフリカではもうアパルトヘイトといってね
まあ黒人はまるっきり別に入れちゃって付き合いはない
全部資源がある土地は自分たち白人だけ取って
水やら農業できるところは自分白人のみ
黒人を何もないところに放り込んで
バスに乗ったらあかんし
黒人用のバスがあったりして
で 水飲む時でもカラン2つあって
白人用 黒人用とかね 便所も2つあって
人に入れない 汚い便所は黒人用で
立派なものは白人でという風にやっていたんですね
で これはマンデラさんとかね
まあ日本以外ね たくさんの国々がね
日本とヨーロッパ以外はね
たくさんの国々がものすごいこれに攻撃して反対して
なんとかなくなりましたけどね
でも黒人は 黒人は逆襲していないんです
あそこまでやられたのに
だからはっきり言えば
黒人はものすごい立派な人間なんですよ
あれほどやられていているのに
いつでも歌ったり踊ったり
冗談言ったり 雰囲気を明るくしたりしているんですよ
恨み持たないんですね
なのに いまだにあっちけという
で あの差別心がない人間ないと言えるぐらいみんな差別心持ってますよ
この差別心は結構便利な道具なんですよ
これで人を殺せます 生命も殺せます
これで弱みはなくなると思います
こんなやり方で弱みをなくなろう
なくそうと思っているんだから
じゃあ理性で考えてください
そんなもので弱みがなくなるわけないでしょう
すべてインチキでしょうに
でも この人間の中でそれが続いています
通ってます それからエゴと自我という
自分のことだけ考えるエゴイストになる
これで強そうと思っているんです
他の生命を 他の命を無視する
無関心になる だからエゴイストの人々は自分だけでよろしいと
他の人々は無関心でね
家族の中でもエゴイストの子供が生まれたら
まあ親は怒鳴るわ 親をぶん殴るわ
こんなものは食えるわけないだろうと言ったりして
食べるものはもう投げ捨てるわ
恐ろしいことをするんですよ
それで親がやっぱり子供は怖いと
と弱音を吐いちゃうんです
だからエゴイストになることも
一つの人間が使う手段なんですね
自分の利益しか見ないことにする
自分の利益だけ考えると
気楽に商売できるんですと思っているんです
これで強がる 強がるんです
しかし ライバルを無視することで
軽視することで自分が負けるという事実もありますが
とりあえずそれは無視
エゴイストになると周りの攻撃を受けて潰され
潰されますけど とりあえず無視
自分の利益のみを考えちゃうと
もうみんなお互いの目で
その会社 その商売を見るんです
自分にも利益がなければ品物を買わないんですよ
だから 自分だけのことを考えちゃうと
自分で生きていられないのにも関わらず
それはとりあえず無視ということにして
結構強者になり上がって頑張っています
それから自分を騙すということをするんですね
前の項も全部自分を騙すことですけど
命が尊い これで生存欲を騙すんです
命が尊いというためにデータが必要です
こういう理由で こういうわけで
こういう証拠があって
命が尊いと ゼロでしょ？皆無でしょ
あれ 命が尊いという人間言ってる単語は生存欲なだけですよ
生存欲が泣いているんです
生きていきたいという
その泣き声なんですね
これ騙されています 本気で思うなら競争はできないんですよ
本気で命が尊いと思ったら
どうやって仲間同士で競争する？どうやって尊い人の商売を破壊する？どうやって戦争で尊い命を殺される？殺せる
嘘でしょ はっきりと しかし
これが本当だと思ってるでしょ
皆様もおそらく命は尊いものやと言ったら気分が良くなると思いますよ
あれが生存欲なんです
騙しなんです それから人間には魂があるというね
西洋哲学の考えあるでしょ
宗教の あれも言い訳ですね
動物を殺すために では
聖書で人間に魂があると言いつつ
なんで戦争に行くんですかね？なんでキリスト教は初めから戦争
戦争 戦い 戦い 十字戦 何て言いますか
えっ？十字軍なんか作ったり殺しに行ったんですかね？何で魔女狩りしたんですかね
なんでバチカンで拷問するために刑務所まで牢屋まであったんですかね
誰にこの嘘を言うんですかね
人間に魂があるんだと
他の生命を殺すためのただの言い訳ですね
これが で 罪を悔い改めると神が許してくれると
また騙し 罪を犯せという話でしょ
命は全知全能の神の計画です
我らはそのまま生きていればよろしいという考えるんです
一切は神が知っています
神が作った世界 だから
そのプログラムに従って生きていればいいんじゃないかなと
そのプログラムは何かというと
ものすごい残酷なプログラムなんですね
弱肉強食 それから人間の場合は共食い
で 正当化するんですね
これは入れたのは これはヒンドゥー教も同じなんです
インドでは貧しい人はいくら頑張っても豊かにならないような組織なんです
カーストの低いカースト制度はきっびしいんです
カースト差別は ずっと政権と財力を握っているのは一部の人間だけなんですよ
世界で2番目に大きい国なんですよ
ものすごい経済的な大国なんです
なのに 世界一貧乏な人々がいるんです
アフリカとかね まあ雨が降らないわ
あるいはソマリアとかね
もうみんな子供たちがもう死んで死んでいくわとか
そこはそれなりの理由がわかりますよ
インドでは ものすごい農業を発達しているし
科学も発達しているし
で 世界にソフトウェアプログラムを作るのはインド人でしょうね
この間 私はアメリカのアマゾンコムにちょっと文句言ってメールを送ったんですね
ある品物を買いたかったんですけど
日本には売りませんと
住所を変えてくださいと
でも昔から私はそちら登録してあったんです
日本アマゾンドットコムJP始まる前から
そこでさっさとメールが返ってきたんですね
あと半年経てば日本にも売ることにしましょうと
言って名前書いて誰ですかと
インド人なんで で 自分の名前で
これでまた何かあったらまあ
繰り返し返しメール送ってくださいと
だからインド人はどこにでも入って頑張っているということでしょうね
しかし インドは貧困な国なんです
どういうことかというと
これ宗教なんですよ 犯人はヒンドゥ教なんです
カースト制度は神が決めたんです
神の定めに文句言わず従うべきです
日本でも人気あるバガヴァッドギーターというテキストをね
日本訳もあります そう
同じことを言っているんです
神の決まりに従いなさいと
だからインドのカースト制度は消えません
人類は解放できません
ガンディさんが正義だと言ってますけどもね
正義でもなんでもないと言いたいんだけどね
まあちょっとやばいんだから却下しますけど
あの それはまた とても家柄の
カーストなんですよ そこで自分の家族の
その社会の その人々のために
インドを独立させてもらったんです
はい それで我々の生き方はそんなもので
次 心の問題に 心の働き
知りたくはない 心の働き
これは知りたくはないと言って
皆様のことではなくて
この逆肉教職の教祖では心を学んだらまずいんですよ
だからやらないんです
心の科学は仏教だけですから
誰もやってないんです
命とは 生きるとは 命とは
生きるととは心の働きです
肉体ではありません 心のことを完全に無視
肉体主義だけ で それで肉体は大したことないんですよ
心が命なんです で その心にも栄養が必要なんです
残念ですから けど 心には有機物は要りません
有機物必要なのは肉体なんです
体を命として生かしているのは心です
体の維持だけでは栄養は足りません
心には栄養が足りません
心の栄養は刺激です 体にも刺激が起こるし
心にも自分で刺激を自家発生し
文章は文法間違ってますけど
で 心も自分で刺激を自家発生しているんです
だから刺激について 食べる時刺激でしょ
走る時刺激でしょ そうやって肉体からも刺激が生まれます
それで心が栄養をもらいます
食べるもので心は栄養をもらいません
食べるものはただの有機物で壊れている部品を入れ替えるだけです
しかし 食べる時 気持ちいいんですね
美味しいんですね 楽しいんですね
それが心の栄養になります
だからみんな体に激悪いものを
あれやこれやとか工夫して
もう 4回油で温めたり炒めたり
いろんなことをして 最後にバターまで上に乗って食ったりするでしょ
で ものすっごい濃い味にして
それで体が壊れますけど
あれは結局心のためなんです
だから人間はほとんど病気でしょうに
テレビで健康食品売っているわ
売っているわ 売っているわ
もうこの国 全体的に病院かい？と聞きたくなるくらい
適正に適量だけ食べればいいのに
恐ろしい味付けをしないで
お塩と醤油と酒とか何とかにつけて
もうもう一晩つけておいてから料理を作るでしょ
それでからまた塩をかけたりとかね
また醤油をかけたり で
それ作ってからこの上また何かかけるんですね
ソースとか ここまで毒にして食ってるのは
あれは心のためなんです
しかし 心には刺激を自家発生することはできます
だから本当は心配する必要はないんです
心はすーっと刺激 自家発生するんです
だって皆様方 いつも怒ったり
悩んだり 恨んだり 妄想したりしているでしょ
興奮したり いろんなことをして
あれは刺激 自家発生なんですね
しかし 無知と生存欲が基礎になる刺激です
これで心が自家発生してくれればありがたいんだけど
この機械は無知と生存欲で働いています
だから我々は刺激を受けようと思っちゃうと
生存欲と無知なんですね
芸術作品を作ったり 音楽を作ったり
いろんなことを考えたり
創作 小説を書いたりとかね
すべて生存欲 いわゆる貪瞋痴
怒り 憎しみ 悲しみ 失望
絶望 別れ そういうものを歌っているでしょ
小説読んだら何があるんですか？中
ただ醜い感情をかき回しているだけで
これで心に栄養を与えているんだと
それ以外 文学作品があったら私にも教えてください
探してさっさと読みます
次に 嫉妬 憎しみ 恨み 落ち込み
慢などの刺激が現れます
生存欲と無知が基礎になったら
嫉妬 怒り 憎しみなどなどの 1500 の感情という刺激の類が生まれてくるんですね
この刺激は破壊的ですね
言うまでもなく 心が作り出す刺激は
生きるという根本的な目的を破壊します
生きていきたいと思うのは肉体じゃないんですよ
心なんですよ 年取りたくないと思うのは体じゃないんです
体にはそれはどうでもいいんです
心が年取りたくないんですよ
痩せたいと思うのは体じゃないんです
体にはどうでもいいんです
動かないほど食べて食べて
至っても体がどんどん大きくなっちゃって動かなくなるだけで
なるだけで体は全然気にもしない
これ痩せたいと思うのは心なんですよ
スマートになりたいと思うのは心なんです
美しくなりたいと思うのは心なんですね
これで刺激を受けるんですよ
気分が良くなったと言うんです
しかし この心が作り出す刺激は
すべて我々の根本的な希望を破壊するんです
根本的な希望が生きていきたいということなんです
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ 争いばっかり妄想しちゃうと
生きることはできなくなるんです
早く死んじゃうんです
より一層激しく戦わなくては
苦しまなくてはならなくなります
心が嫉妬やら落ち込みやら嘘やら傲慢やら作っちゃうと
生きる戦いがさらに難しくなります
生きるとは残酷極まりであるという現実を作り出す犯人は自分の心です
というわけで 生きるとは残酷の極まりなんです
美しくないんです 尊くないんです
では この残酷極まりのない生存が誰が作ったかというと
心が作ったんです お釈迦様の言葉で言えば
心に生きていきたいという執着
愛着があるんだから 輪廻転生を限りなくやってますよと
無明と渇愛のせいで 生命は無限に生死を回転していますよと
だから皆様にこの世界だけに限って喋りましたけど
仏教は輪廻というところで喋りますから
この残酷さっていうのはもう想像を絶するものなんです
考えてください 理解しなくてもいいんです
我々は死んでもまた再び生まれると
また死んでもまた再び生まれると思ったら
どこまで残酷かと 心が思う生きる技
すべて逆効果になります
逆結果になります これよくこの文章だけでもいいんだから暗記してください
なぜかというと 我々は生きるためにどんな計らいしようか
どんなからくりしようか
それ全て生きることは逆にさせるんです
生きていられなくなるんです
逆効果なんです 何やっても
農業開発するとかなり危険なこと結果になる
食べ物自体信頼できないものになっていく
工場は あれやこれやと作って
品物を作れば作るほど
かなり危険な状態に陥る
教育レベルが発達すればするほど
生きることが苦しくなっていく
すべて逆効果なんです
矛盾から始めて矛盾で終わる命
強者が弱者を餌食にすることは矛盾です
強者も必ず弱者になりますから
だから俺が強者だからあなたを食ってやると思っても
お前も食われますよと
だから あの考えは矛盾です
自己を守る目的のエゴ
自我が矛盾です なんで我々はエゴイストかというと
自分を守るためなんですよ
弱者だから自我でも張って
強者のように振り回ろうと思っているのですが
これが矛盾です だから攻撃を受けて潰れますからね
エゴ張らないエゴイストだからやられるんですよ
自我張るとやられるんですよ
だから自分が弱者だったったら
まあそれでいいでしょう
控えめでいれば これ自我張っちゃってやられるんで
だからそれも矛盾です
自分を騙すために作る様々な思考概念は矛盾です
生きる戦いそのものが矛盾です
そこで上の行なんですけど
我々いろんな思考を作ってるでしょ
宗教を作ってるでしょ
哲学を作ってるでしょ
学問を作ったでしょ すべて矛盾です
命を助けてくれないんです
生きることは苦しくなるだけです
例えば宇宙の研究をしているでしょ
あれ 何のためですかね
あれ 強者になるためなんですよ
俺は宇宙のことを知ってるんだぞと
勝手にやりなさいと あれで必要な財産がなくなるだけでしょ
そういうことで 思考概念も矛盾です
全部 で 生きる戦いそのものが矛盾です
なぜみんな死ぬんだから
必ず死ぬから 矛盾から始めて矛盾で終わる
あの聖書で神がこう言うんです
我はアルファであってオメガであると
偉い威張ってる言葉なんですね
すべてのものは私から始めて私で終わっちゃいますよと
それだけでも残酷な言葉ですけど
アルファっていうのは文字のあれ
アルファベットの 1 で
オメガっていうのはギリシア文字の最後ですね
であの 神はユダヤ人ですけど
ギリシア語で新約聖書を書くんですからね
で 私が言いたいのは 命のアルファもオメガも矛盾ですと
だから矛盾です 我はというところに矛盾ということを入れちゃえば
生きていきたいという絶対的な希望も矛盾です
決して叶わない で 決して叶わない希望を持つこと自体矛盾
矛盾でしょ 例えば皆様一人が私は老後好きに住みたいんだと言ってみてください
笑われちゃうでしょ だから決して叶わない希望を持つっていうことは
いかにアホらしかと だから生きていきたいと
これも矛盾です 生老病死に対する戦いも矛盾です
我々は生きることで生老病死と闘っていますね
矛盾です 勝てません 生老病死が生きることです
これなく生きていられません
生きるとは生老病死なんです
なんで戦うんですかね
生きていきたいでしょ
敵を倒すことが矛盾です
無数の敵を新たに作る行為だからです
人類は敵を倒すことばっかり考えていますよね
それ矛盾です 欲 怒り 嫉妬
競争心などの感情も矛盾です
生かしてくれるエネルギーではなく
命を破壊するエネルギーだからです
みんな欲で怒りで自我で生きているでしょう
これが生きがいにしているでしょう
あれが猛毒で生きることはなくなるんです
それで 神創造論 運命論なども矛盾です
唯物論も矛盾です 物質に生きていきたいという衝動は生まれません
科学者は結構唯物論でしょ
日本でも唯物論は結構人気ありますけど
あれ矛盾です 生きていきたいと物質は思いません
で 神は明らかに矛盾でしょ
創造論というのはまるっきり成り立たないでしょ
すべて運命やと思うのはね
いい加減でしょ 人間優越論も矛盾です
細菌にも負ける 人間が偉いと何言ってます？細菌に負けてるくせに
幸福を目指すことも矛盾です
これが不幸を重ねる道だからです
我々は幸福になりたいと思って不幸の世界を作ったでしょ
不幸しかない世界を作ったでしょ
だから人間 間違ってでもこういうふうになりたいと思ったらあかんで
これ矛盾なんですよ 怖いんですよ
幸福になりたいと思ったら何するかわからないんだから
次に知識の矛盾 他の生命を攻撃するための人間の武器は知識です
あの なんですね  ライオンにはね
もうきつい強い手があってね
牙があって ライオンが手でやっちゃえば
もうどんな動物も死んじゃいますよ
そういうふうに蛇には毒があったりして
みんな武器持ってます
他の生命を殺して食べるために
人間には角もないし 足も速くないし
体もすっごく弱いんですね
人間より小さな猿が人間と攻撃したっても
人間が負けるんです 人間が動きが鈍いんです
小さな猿でも人間と戦うと勝てます
なのに人間にはすごい武器があります
それは知識です 知識があるんだから
猿は人間に勝てません
知識があるんだから 熊も人間には勝てません
細菌には負けてはいるんだけど
でも相当我々は頑張って競争はしています
この武器で何の利益もないにも関わらず
大量に無差別に残酷に殺しをやっているんです
だから知識があったら
食うぐらいの生命を殺しちゃえばいいでしょう
ではないでしょ 知識を武器を振り回って
あらゆる残酷なことをやっているんです
余計なことをやっています
何の利益もないのに戦争するんです
人を殺すんです しかし
失敗するたびに戦いは良くない
怒り 嫉妬 欲は良くない
仲良くした方が良いなどの気持ちも生じます
とんでもない連中ですね
人間が欲は良くないっていうのは
欲を出して損した時なんですよ
うかつに株を買ってはいけないっていうのは
自分の貯金全部なくなった時なんですね
人間の道徳っていうのはそんな程度なんですよ
だからこの知識は矛盾でしょ
生きていられないんだから
あるいは生きるために付いたものでしょ
その気持ちと根本的な生きる衝動がまた矛盾します
根本的には生きていきたいという衝動があるで
それは逆の動きをしろでしょ
これで戦ってはならん
怒ってはならんというと
うかつに言うなよと それは矛盾です
だからはっきり言います
仏教以外 世の中で言っている
嘘を言ってはいけません
怒ってはいけません みんなに優しくしましょうというのはすべて矛盾なんです
どこかでやられているでしょうね
どこかで失敗しているでしょう
平和を謳っているが 心は平和を好まないんです
道徳を語るが 自分では守りたくはないんです
自分が思うこと 自分の生き方
考え 主義のみが正しいと思っているんです
これって相当な矛盾でしょ
私が思っていることは正しいと
これで戦いに行くんです
それで他人と戦いに挑む
はい これから仏教の世界に入りましょう
生きるとは何かと発見もしないで生きようとすることで
すべて矛盾が生じるんです
なんでここまで全て一切矛盾になったんですかね
数学さえも矛盾だから
これは生きるとは何かとを勉強していないんです
だからすべて矛盾から始めて
無知から始めているんです
それが無知であるとまず理解しましょう
我々はすべて無知からスタートしていますよと
命は尊い価値がある 生存欲
死に対する恐怖 すべて矛盾です
無知です だからこういうものが生まれてくるんです
無知から生まれてくるんです
知識は無知から現れます
人類の膨大な知識は矛盾
無知の上にできたものです
いくら知識を得ても無知が消えません
知識そのものも無知なんです
無知を破って智慧を開発することが仏教です
だからこれは超人法なんです
人類すべて無知という台に立っているんです
これを破りましょうと
一切の生命の生きる衝動は無知なので
それを破ること自体が超人の境地です
だから人間にブッダが言うのは
超人に いわゆる人間を超えましょうと
無知を破るということは超人法です
生きたいのではなく 生きる衝動
煩悩を破ることも超人法で
お釈迦様は生きたい生きたいではなくて
これ恐ろしいんだからやめましょうよと
乗り越えましょうよと
輪廻を乗り越えましょうよと
これが超人法なんです
一般人に理解できない
生死の繰り返しを乗り越えることは超人法です
ブッダが語る道徳と実践は
超人法に達する道です
仏教には道徳があります
世間にはありません これも超人に達する道なんですね
はい では共存という言葉に入りましょう
超人法はここからスタートします
共存からスタートします
まず 生命は平等です これは明らかな事実なんです
皆様の知識 人類の知識
何と言おうとも 生命は平等です
客観的に生きることを調べると
生命は皆 基本的には平等であることを発見します
形と生き方が変わっても
皆生きていきたい 死にたくないという希望で生きているんでしょうに
ミミズと私が違いますけど
食べるものも違うでしょ
しかし 生きてきた死にたくないは同じですよ
他の希望を応援すると
他も自分を応援する 最低でも敵視することはなくなるんです
だから世の中でないやり方を教えるんです
生命を殺して食うんじゃなくて
生命を応援しなさいと
みんな生きたがっているんだから
どうぞ幸福で無事生きてくださいと
応援しますと言うと 他の生命も私を応援してくれる
私の命を これで自分の希望叶ってるでしょ
生きていきたいという
本当に慈しみを実践すると
細菌も攻撃しないんですよ
細菌も攻撃しない いくら流行ってもね
いろいろインフルエンザとかあれやこれやとかね
感染しない だから我々のこの破壊の道ではなくて
生命を応援するということを選ばなくてはいけないんですね
それは慈しみというんですね
ます生命を慈しんでみるんです
普通の生命ならやらないことなので
ここから超人へに超人への道に入るんです
あの慈しみ生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにと念じ始めたところから
皆様方は人間を乗り越える道を進んでいるんです
超越した人間になる道をも歩み始めているんです
シンプルで聞こえますけど
そうじゃないんです すごいものなんです
敵もライバルも減っていくので
幸福に穏やかに生きられるようになります
生かすことが生きる道
生きる生きる道だと理解するのです
生きたければ生かしてくださいと
それで道徳が自ずから現れます
今の道徳って嫌々でやってるでしょ
怖いんだからやってるでしょ
バレたら大変だから嘘をつかないだけでしょ
バレなかったら何でもやっちゃいますからね
これ消えます 自然に道徳になります
慈しみによって 殺生は良くない
他人のものを取ってはならない
嘘をついて騙してはならない
他を恨んだり 他に怒ったりしてはいけないなどなどの道徳がとても自然に
自然な生き方であると理解する
これが呼吸するような自然な生き方になってしまいますよ
もう超人でしょ？嘘ついといけない
いけないんだからではなくて
嘘つかない 人のを盗んではいけない
あ これバレたら大変なことになりますとかね
仕事も首になる そんな何もないんです
慈しみがあるんだからね
それないだけ だから物の見事に完璧に道徳守る人間に成り代わり成り代わっているんです
生まれ変わっているんです
普通の人間とは桁違い
聖人に成りかかっているんです
心が落ち着く それから
だって怖いものないでしょう
敵がいないし 知恵が現れるんです
次 真の自由を発見します
それ終わったら 次のステップに自動的に成長します
これは自由ということです
生命は個で自由に生きたい
他人に支配されたくはないという気持ちを持っていることを発見します
それは難しい発見ではないんですね
生命は個で 個人で すべての生命は
人に 他人に支配されてほしくないんです
だから 各生命に自由という気持ちが潜んでいるんです
自由になりたいという
これを発見するんです
自分の欲で 自分の利益のために他に執着することはいけない
成り立たない 争いの原因になると発見します
結構結婚なんか失敗するのはそういうわけなんです
自分のために相手を束縛しようとするんです
それは成り立たない たとえ結婚しても
だから所有欲が強くなると離婚になるんです
自分の子供だからといって
子供は自分じゃないんで
自分のものじゃないんで自由です
これで子供に対する愛着
所有欲が強くなると 子供はものすごい悪い人間になって
親を殺して逃げるんです
だからこれわかった人が最高に幸せでしょう
人間関係は抜群にうまくいくでしょう
物事に対する執着を減らす
次に 物事に対する執着も減らすんです
こんないらんだろうと
私個人の人生のためにはね
服は 300着はいらんだろうと
あれ エメラルダ夫人という
フィリピンのね もうトラック 4台ぐらい靴はいらんでしょう
生きていきたいという自分のことを観察すると
生きていきたいという自分を観察するんですね
それを観察する 体も心も無常で
因縁によって一時的に現れる現象であることを発見します
そうすると 生きるということは不思議なもので
すーっと変わるんだと
肉体も変わっていくんだ
心も変わっていくんだ
その都度変わるんだとかね
例えば外に行ったら寒いと感じるでしょ
これで体変わっちゃったんですよ
心も変わるんですよ ただ環境から
だから命って何やと ただ単に蜃気楼みたいな
ちょっとしたね もう えっとえっとえっと
レインボーって何でしたっけ？虹
ちょっと三角形のあれに光を当てたら虹が見えるものでしょ
そんなような まあ一時的なものやと
とわかるんですよ 執着の値するものは存在すらしないと発見します
今は執着ばっかりでしょ
生存欲 しかし 欲に値するものは存在すらしないんです
何もないんです ただ蜃気楼を追っているだけ
ミスだ ミスだ ミスだと思って
壁に書いた虫を食ってやるぞと思っているだけ
あの仏教では禅でもね
空月というね 空に咲く花とかね
あるわけないでしょ これなんて美しいですかと舞い上がってるだけ
ないのに 心は束縛から離れる
自由になる 解脱に達する
これで完了になるんです
すべて喜損から始まるんです
超人になります 聖者になります
...美しく安らぎの世界
今まで私が説明したのは
ものすごい醜い 共食いの
あまりにも残酷極まりの世界なんです
これが逆にして見せます
醜い争い世界が共存という生き方で
初めて平和が訪れる 恐怖が消え
安らぎと安穏が現れます
共存から始まると 人間が作り出した一切の矛盾的な生き方が消えるんです
世界のすべての問題に対する解決策は仏道にあるんです
人間持ってくる問題というのは
何であろうとも 仏教には答えがあるんです
絶対的正しい答え 唯一の正解
仏教にあるんです これが共存というところから始まるんです
はい 終わりです えっと
まあ少々時間は残りましたけど
質問等があれば  先生は荷物をどのぐらい持ちなんでしょうか
私はいろんなものを やっぱり皆さんからもらった大事な年賀状とかお手紙とか
あとは先生の聞いた勉強した資料とかはやっぱり捨てられないので
今まだ多分捨てられないままになってるんですよ
それも今日お話しされた共存の反対なのか
何かと戦っているのかしらというのがわからなくて
ちょっともしヒントがいただければと思いました
お願いいたします  あの私たちはね
まだまだ勉強中だから
我々の人格向上するためにね
まあそういうものは必要でしょう
それからまだ生きているんだからね
やっぱり暖房も必要しね
毛布も必要でしょう 本当はまあそういう程度でね
これは必要 これが必要
これが必要というふうにラベルを貼ってみたら
まあそれぐらいは持ってるのは持つのは一向に構わないと言っても
私の部屋にもいらんものはいっぱいありますよ
私も時々これはいらない
いらない いらない いらない
いらないと指をさしていくんだけど
あれ処分するのめんどくさくてね
いわゆるね まあすごいお金もかかるし
電話して呼んでもらって
まあいいや 明日にするということで
そのまんまになっているんです
本当は実際使うの使っているのはほんのわずかなんです
皿とか食器ももうだいたい三人分ぐらいあると思います
けど 私は毎日一つの皿しか使ってないんです
で まあサラダとか食べますけど
大きいラーメンを食べる時の使う丼みたいあって
それにサラダを入れて
それ食べて 次に豆腐も食べたいと思ったら
次にそれに入れて一つで食べているんです
だったら全部処分すればいいのにね
ね まあこれ社会状況もありましてね
ゴミは簡単にね そういうことですから
正直なところいっぱいあります
ゴミは はい あの自由にいろいろ質問してください
はい どうぞどうぞ  真ん中の方の男性の方
先ほどちょうどおっしゃった輪廻転生についてなんですけど
具体的に輪廻転生とはどういうことなのかというのをお聞きしたいと思いまして
普通はなんかその魂があって生まれ変わるという
そういうことだと認識しているんですけど
長老の考えたテーラワーダのっていうテーラワーダの輪廻転生というのはどういうことか
あの これは心と物質の流れの話なんですね
だから私たちは一般的に宗教の影響があって
我は死んでどこかに生まれるという
このアイデンティティを探してるでしょ
で これが難しいんです
今も私にはアイデンティティがないんで
こうですけど 赤ちゃんで生まれたのに
もうまるっきりもう覚えてもないんですね
もうもう全部 心も体も死んでしまっちゃったんですね
しかし その代わりに新しいものが生まれるんですね
だから我々は今も輪廻転生しているんです
瞬間瞬間 それで何か消えると何か生まれるという因果法則があるんですね
これはあの リンゴが消えると新たなリンゴが生まれるわけじゃないんです
私はリンゴ食っちゃったらリンゴが消えちゃったんですね
もう二度と現れないんだけど
別な何かが生まれているんですね
だからこの探すのは難しいんです
私も昨日リンゴを 1個食べたんですけど
で 今そのエネルギー使っているはずですけど
見つからないんですね
だからこの心っていうのは
瞬間 瞬間 瞬間 瞬間 ずっと電気のようにものすごいスピードで変化しているんですね
だからその流れに輪廻転生というんです
魂という概念を教えている宗教のように
魂の引っ越し 露天移転ではないんです
それならわかるはずなんですね
私の過去はどうでしたか？ということはね
だから輪廻転生あると言ったっても全然面白くないんですよ
まず残酷な生き方になるし
だから私個人で過去で何か心があって
その心がなくなったら
新たな心が人間の世界で現れちゃっただけ
でもそれによって今生きてるんですけど
過去何やったかどうかさっぱりわからないし
このアイデンティティ見つかることもできない
このアイデンティティということが問題
それが我々頭の中にあるんだからね
それ妄想概念ですけど
結構輪廻転生のことでみんなわからないという風になっちゃうんです
それはどうせ難しいんですね
一応あのエネルギーの流れだと思ってくださいね
エネルギーっていうのは形変わって変えては流れるんですね
止まらないでしょ だから肉体よりは心のエネルギーは強いでしょ
だって生きたり 喋ったり
泣いたり 笑ったり 建物を作ったり
新幹線作ったり それ心でしょ
やってるのは だから心のエネルギーは強いんですよ
それはまあ 消えるっていうことはちょっと非科学的ですね
とにかく因果法則から見れば
もう消えては現れる 消えては現れるなんです
例えば今光があるでしょ
これは電気が消える 光が現れる
この光には電気と全く性質が違うんですね
私たちには光を見て これはこんな電気
電池 電気でしょと言えないでしょ
あ これはアルカリ電池の光ですと
これはもう充電式の電池のリチウム電池の光です
言える？言えないでしょ
そういうことで アイデンティティはなくなっちゃうんですね
あるのは関連性のみ それでよろしいですか？はい
どうぞ  すいません ちょうどそのことをお話してもらって
心は瞬間瞬間に消えていくもんで
自分というのも 1 秒前と現在と 1 秒先の自分は変わっているというふうに理解しているんですけれど
はい 過去 私が過去において犯した数々の悪行ですね
人に嫌なことをしたとか
嫌なことを言ったとか
そういうカルマみたいなものも瞬間瞬間で消えていくというか
あるいはそれは自分が覚えてたらそれは消えないのか
自分が忘れたらそのカルマは消えるものなのか
そのところをちょっとお伺いしたいんですけれども
うん えーとですね この関連性ということを使ったんですね
関連性あるんだから逃げられませんね
それは自分が忘れてもダメですか
忘れるっていうことがね
あまり大したことじゃないんですね
で あの 例えばあるエネルギーのある川の流れがあるとしましょう
我々は何とか工夫して川に力を入れると
川の流れが変わるんですね
これがもうどうしようもないんですね
だからまあ 例えばね ホースでずっと水を上に上げちゃうと
やっぱりエネルギーによってある程度上がってから
そのエネルギーが消えてから落ちるんですね
そういう風にこの行いをするたびに心にエネルギーが入るんです
だからエネルギーはエネルギーを足したら
ずっと我々は心に刺激ということでエネルギーを上げているんですよ
でなきゃ その瞬間瞬間
心では我々は心でやることできなくなるんで
それエネルギーが必要ですよ
それで我々は刺激ということでエネルギーを与えているんです
絶えず与えているんです
で 何か行いをしたっていうことは
心にエネルギーを与えたってことなんですね
それによって 次の日かいつか何とかの変化は起こります
で 犯した悪行を思い出すと
さらにエネルギーにもなります
刺激になりますからね
一応忘れた方がいいと思います
で なぜかというと 忘れたら初めて作ったエネルギーだけで
まあそれでそれなりの結果を出して
それ終わります 思い出して思い出してやっちゃうと
エネルギーがもう新しく新しく生まれちゃいますから
後悔は仏教は断言禁止するんですね
ではなくて 悪いことをしましたと認めて
正直に立派な威勢の心でこれからしっかり頑張りますと言うと
悪行為も自分を成長するエネルギーに仕えます
が あまりエネルギーは結果出さずには消えません
消える場合もあります
結果出さずに 一応消えませんというのはブッダの言葉なんですね
確実にではなくて エネルギーが弱ければ
あるいは弱くさせたならば
例えば過去に悪いことをしたとしましょう
このエネルギーはなんとか工夫して弱くする
そうすると結果出さないでそのまま消える可能性はあります
覚えているか忘れるかということは
あまり大したことじゃないんです
よろしいですか はい  どうぞ
前の方の方  今日はマイクないんだから
どうぞ勝手に よろしくお願いします
はい  先日 ある病院にもすり込みまして
なんか小山があったんですけど
その上に木に隠れるようにして小屋がありまして
見に行ってみたら カラスが罠にかかって出られなくなってたんですね
で それを見てちょっと調べたりして
なんか年間 40 万羽のカラスが殺されているみたいで
でもカラスは全然数は減っていなくて
テレビを見た時にすごい気力になって
ちょっと怒りが教えてきてしまって
なんかそれも牧羊的じゃないなと思いまして
どのような気持ちでこういう現実と向き合っていけばいいのかということが一つと
あともう一つあるんですけども
あの釈迦様がもしあのスーパーとかで買い物したとしたら
肉は買わないんじゃないかなと思うんですよ
それで ガンディーが教えがあったかどうかはわからないんですけど
やっぱり身をつけて自然に落ちるものを食べるべきなのかなっていう気持ちがありまして
なんかその この考え方に執着はしないんですけど
やっぱり生きたいと思っている生命は取らないべきなんじゃないかなと思っています
この辺よろしくお願いします
だから  これはあの 答えづらいといえば答えづらいんですね
皆様方の世間の価値観から考えるんだから
どうしても矛盾に陥っちゃいますね
例えばカラスはとってもとっても数は減らないとかね
カラスは障害 迷惑やとかね
これはえらい矛盾でしょ
だから人間だけえらいっていう考えでしょ
それも嘘でしょうに だから
カラスをなんで管理するんですかね
放っておけばいいでしょうに
自然は自然のバランスというものがありますから
これは別に人間がなんで壊すんですかね
カラスを取るっていうこと自体
自然のバランスを壊すことですよ
で 私には自分の国で小さい時はカラスは人間にとって何て言いますか
味方になる動物であると教えられたんです
で なぜかというと 自然の中で人間も含めて生きている場合はいっぱいゴミを出すんだと
それで特に生ゴミは危険だと
カラスは全部食べてくれるんだと
だからカラスいた方が環境は美しくなるんだと
ゴミ処理はもう最近ちょっとちょっと国でもできているんですけど
今までなかったんですけど
綺麗です それでもあちらで死んだ動物とか
たまたま動物結構いるんですけどもね
死骸はないんです だからスカベンジャー bird というのは
スカベンジャーっていうのはゴミを処理するということでね
だから我々はね 自然の法則を守っていれば
カラスはありがたい存在になりますよ
うーん おっしゃった次のポイントなんですけどね
自然に与えられるものだけ食べていればね
まあ本当に気分がいいんですけどね
それもよく気持ちもわかりますし
理論もよくわかります
例えばリンゴっていうのは食べた方がいいでしょう
一番私はおかしいと思うのはバナナなんですよ
バナナっていうのは人間にとってみれば完全な栄養なんですね
バナナ 1本  2本ぐらい食べれば十分な食事一つなんですね
それで私が思うのは バナナの木とは言えないんだけど
なんでバナナの木はバナナ作るんですかと
何の そのバナナという植物に対して何の利益もないんです
そこで花が出てバナナが出るでしょ
それでバナナの木は死ぬんです
人間食べようか食べないか関係なく実ったら死ぬんです
やっぱり死ぬ前に美味しいバナナ作ってあげようということをね
種もないしね だから明らかに人間よりは性格いいでしょ
自分に利益もないのに
これまたものすごい美味しいもの
作ってくれる それで動物は食べますし
あの花のバナナの花の中にも大量に蜜があるんです
ものすごい量なの 私は小さい時取って取って
花蜜を飲んだ覚えがあるんです
結構量があるんです だからミツバチにしてみれば
一本のバラの花で大量に作れます
私はすごい立派やと思いますよ
バナナの木は はい 人間食べることになると
人間がやっぱりあのバナナの木にはいくらかお世話する
あの母の木が死んじゃうと
子供の木がたくさん一箇所で現れるんですよ
根元から しかし もう栄養を取っちゃったんだから
子供たちには成長できないんです
病気になってすぐ死ぬんです
それで人間があの穴を掘って
全部根元から全部取り上げて
小さな小さな芽が出たものを全部切って
新しいところで新しく穴を掘って
植えて植えて植えて植えてあげてるんです
みんな必ずバナナを実ります
だから そういうことで
農業をやっている方々は
バナナの木にはいくらかはサービスはしています
しかし 猿はやってないんです
ただ食べて出ている 逃げてるだけ
そういうふうにバナナを取って食べることは
やっぱり誰にも迷惑と迷惑をかけてないということになりますね
とは言ってもね この肉体の場合はね
バナナだけで生きてられるかどうか
いろいろまた問題も出てくる
だから まあそこら辺はまあお釈迦様の答え
これ矛盾が出てくるんだからね
例えば自分で魚を殺さなくても
まあ売ってる魚買って食べたりはすることはできますし
だからまあ魚食べて体に悪いかというと悪くはないし
でも死んじゃったんだからね
ですから私たちはやっぱりこの慈しみを常に幸福でありますように
幸福でありますようにと
いう気持ちでやるしかないんだと
干し魚を焼いて食べても構わないんだけど
まあなんとかこの命も幸福であってほしいと
もう命はもうとっくに前に亡くなっていたんだからね
それで最後の質問もすごい面白いんです
お釈迦様がスーパーに行ったならば
肉を買わないだろうというね
で 面白いことを考えるんですね
これには 答えられませんね
私の場合はもうギリギリ遠慮する
もう避けますね で お釈迦様はもっと精密に出家ということでね
出家とは この生きる循環から逃げたんですね
生きる循環は残酷ですね
それで 出家ですから もうお釈迦様は完全にね
私たちみたいなね もう生ハンカチいい加減な出家じゃないんです
で 肉を買わないところか
木に実っている果物も取らないんです
これは他人のものということで
だから托鉢するんです
托鉢したら 炊いたご飯
米は受け取れません 炊いたご飯は一人分だけ
まあ一匙くらいはいただく
で 足りなかったら次の家にも行く
焼いたパンだったらいただく
小麦粉はダメという そういうふうに命が亡くなったもの
例えば焼いたパンは次
運命は何ですかね 腐るだけでしょう
それが体を通してあげれば
自分の命がつなげますね
そういうふうに この托鉢で矛盾のない
罪のない生き方をサンプルとして見せたんですね
皆様にはこれは無理ですよ
仕事しなくちゃあかんだからね
だからある程度で悪いことをする羽目になります
だから 魚を食べてもいいんだけど
釣りはやめた方がいいし
肉を食べるのはいいんですけど
だから肉はおいしいんだから
私はもう動物を育って殺して売りますということはやめた方がよろしいし
売っているものの場合は
こう再現の方々こう考えればいいんで
今はこちらに肉という物体がある
これ もともと持っていた生命はもう殺されて死んでもういないんですと
肉の将来は腐って消えるだけなんですね
だからそれがカラス食べるか
あるいは微生物食べるか
俺は食べるかっていう程度のことなんですね
じゃあ俺は食べるぞと
どうせこれからこちらの命がないという程度で
しかし 生命がみんな幸福でありますようにと気持ちでやらなくちゃいけないと思いますね
明確な答えはちょっと難しいんですね
そんな程度にしてください
はい あと 1個ぐらい質問あればよろしいです
なければそれで時間になってます
はい どうぞ  人間というのは
自分で判断して 自分でこう良し悪しを決めて
自分で喜んでいるっていうふうに考えても
うん ちょっと最後は聞こえなかった
自分で考えて  自分で考えて
自分で良し悪しを判断して
それで喜んだり悲しんだり
それは人間はやること
人間にはこの生き延びるために武器があったでしょ
あるでしょ 知識というね
それが生き延びるためじゃなくて
もう生きることを破壊するところまで武器を振り回しているんですね
だから まあいろんなことを自分で考えるし
自分で考えるしかないしね
人が考えてくれないしね
問題はこの誤解に基づいて考えることをやめましょう
人間が唯一素晴らしい存在だとかね
いつでも人間至上主義でね
例えばカラスを処分するべきだとかね
あれやこれやとかね そういう人間至上主義で考えるのはおかしいと思って
生命は平等であるというところに共存というところを入れて
それから考えれば正しい思考が現れると思います
それで喜びますよ いいことを考えちゃうと
それは構わないと思います
人間はどうても考えます
それは止めることはできません
それで考える方法が間違ってますから
それを直しましょうよというところですね
これは仏教の発想道で正思惟といって
正しく考えましょうというふうに教えられていますね
正しく考えるということは
怒り 欲 嫉妬の感情を捨てて
慈しみで考えることなんですね
そういうふうに頑張ってみましょう
なぜ止めることができないのかがこう
それは刺激が入るんだからね
心が止めたら死んじゃうでしょ
だからこれは止められません
瞑想で止められますけどね
それも瞑想といっても
このブッダの悟りの瞑想で
かなりの進んだ時は ほんのわずかな時間は停止することはできます
それ以外は無理です これは地球の自転
ちょっとやめてみようかなというぐらいのものなんです
心は宇宙法則より強いんですよ
回転はするんです 止まられません
で ヴィパッサナー実践で解脱に達することしか心を止める方法はないんです
よろしいですか？ん？だから止められないと
だから自分やってみてください
心を止めてみるぞと だって生きていること自体心でしょ
なぜ次から次へと湧いてくるのか
なぜ次から次へとそういう風に自分で決めてしまうのか
っていう それは前に前の衝動というか
刺激が次の心を作っちゃうんですね
どういう基準で決めてしまうのか
基準って因果法則でしょ
だからその時その時入った刺激によって心が変わっちゃいます
法則はそれだけです 例えばいきなりこちら
誰かが若者が来て いきなり音楽を流して踊り出したとしましょう
いきなり皆様の心変わっちゃいますよ
これどうにもならんですね
そういうことで 環境から入る情報によって心はずっと変わって変わっていくんです
それは難しいことじゃないんです
踊り出すというのは邪魔だなというふうに勝手に判断する
邪魔だな 面白いだな 何でもいいんです
もしここで何人か踊ると
決して私を見ないでしょう
邪魔だなと思ったっても
何やってるの？と思ったっても
心がそちらに行くんです
なぜならば そちらの刺激が多いんです
一人一人は勝手に面白いなって思ったり
邪魔だなと思ったり そのものが判断するっていう
そうそう 例えば邪魔だなと思った人が私の話を聞きたいという気持ちがあったんですね
面白いなと思った人が
この話よりはこれという
そのその条件によって変わるんですね
はい もう時間になりましたので
これを説明します はい
どうもありがとうございます
それでは最後に皆さんで回向の文を唱え
終了したいと思います
ご一緒にしてください
回向の文 仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
限りを奉り 慈悲の誓願とヴィパッサナー修行によって得られたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
友人に分配し 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものは幸福に生きられますように
そして 偉大な偉大としますように
サッビートゥアジャンツーサッバローボーウィナッサトゥマーテーラワントラーヨサティディーガーユコーバババウトゥサッバマンガラントゥサッバデヴァタサッバブッ
ダヌーバヴェーナサッバダンマヌーバヴェーナサッバサンガヌーバヴェーナサダスッティバワントゥティアビワパナシーリッサニッチャンヴァッダパチャイノーチャッタ
ローダンマヴァッダンティアーユワンノーシュタンバラン
では 中井寺さん どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます